good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday we're
so close to
friday
so exciting beautiful thursday it's
actually a beautiful day here in the
city and it's thursday which makes the
weather and
everything a bit brighter plus do to do
is here you know what he chose to sit
with yet andy i'm [ __ ] sick of this
[ __ ] i really am i haul ass here i get
sweaty every day walking over here and i
walk because i bring theo and every
[ __ ] day he sits next to you and you
know what i'm [ __ ] fed up leo
anti-file you know what i used to feel
bad because you didn't have a dog now
you do theo come here i've got brew and
do come here yes come on come on
the reason why he came and sat with me
was because i was eating a cliff bar so
what okay yes
yes come here
it's your mom
it's not that deep i feel like i'm
literally like you know
like the hard-working mom and then the
cool auntie comes over and like the kid
loves the auntie and i'm just like the
mean mom who enforces the rules you know
yeah who just taunted him with an empty
cliff bar jackie i'm a joan cusack in
raising helen and you
i'm helen you're helen that's very true
i mean do and i have a special bond he
usually does sit with you
but now he's torn
he's like that tick tock challenge theo
come here angel
okay we need to move on he'll make his
choice in due time in due time well it's
thursday everyone hope you had a great
week so far i'm so excited to even
though it's like only a three day week
four day week for us i'm so excited that
friday's almost upon us i hope everyone
has their weekend plans settling in
getting excited
looks like he made his dream wow theo
just jumped back on jackie's couch
choices were made
it's fine
you know what you know what i think he's
sitting next to me honestly
because i am wearing new morning toast
fall merch drops next week we'll give
you the decent second that's why and i
just feel like he knows that in order to
sell this merch and make it look amazing
his presence needs to accompany it so
look i have a new merch here too this is
a new sweatshirt design it says the
morning toast this color is green i'm
wearing a size medium and we're dropping
some sickening styles on tuesday this
coming tuesday so gird your loins
prepare yourselves we'll be showing you
all of the different
styles that we have new phone cases new
phone cases we've got t-shirts we've got
t-shirts we've got like some cute sets
so stay tuned for all of that but i
think that dude just wants to make sure
that my frame where i'm showcasing the
new merch looks as good as possible i'm
trying to move past this i really am but
like my feelings are really hurt like i
can't lie like what i should just i
should just not say how i'm feeling you
should just move the [ __ ] on yeah no
theo
are you for real i love him just come
sit with me i'm your mom
i'm just craving theo and like he's
literally just abandoning me for his
auntie you gotta get a grip no come i
love you
he has autonomy he has rights and he
made his choice but i just don't think
he was in the right head space that's
what it is you think cause she was under
the influence 100 by the new sickening
merch
and that's how sickening the merch is
we're foolishly much of the warehouse
because everything
is just sticking the warehouse down as
per usual anyway stay tuned for all of
the styles we'll be showing you over the
next few days it's really cute stuff and
it's the first of many sickening
warehouse drops that are coming towards
the end of the year like i would just
i'm just quaking your boots okay
no like fall winter fw 2021
that's the year yeah it's really our
season also spring summer joggers for
sure but like we really thrive oh in
fall winter it's crazy how long it takes
me to get dressed in warm weather and
how like literally i got ready today in
five minutes yeah it's a beautiful thing
and i'm not sweating in my sleep so i
don't really have to run a blow dryer
through my hair like it's just
i need to live in antarctica yeah that
those are my peeps
um i have two things to say one there's
a new episode up on the patreon and i'm
just saying
people are saying people are saying that
it's the best vlog ever that's what
they're saying and you know what i
literally put my heart and soul into the
recording of it the editing of it it
took me all day yesterday and i'm so
proud of the fruits of my labor and it's
a vlog it's a second episode for the
month of october
and it was supposed to be a vlog of my
trip to visit olivia in florida
but um i like dropped the ball a little
bit like i forgot like i was doing
really good and then i literally forgot
to vlog for two days so then i decided i
wasn't gonna let that footage go to
waste because we got pieces of k in that
footage yeah so like you know what i'm
going on another trip let me make this a
two-parter so i vlogged my bender in
puerto rico with brian and i don't know
there's kind of like a a triumphant
unexpected ending do you agree
yeah i watched it last night i enjoyed
it so immensely it felt like for me the
closest i'll come to going on vacation
anytime soon now i agree it was an
amazing vlog and i really like it was 30
minutes i put it on my tv and i just was
living life but it does hurt when we've
done over a hundred vlogs we're both in
them and then the one i'm not in best
vlog ever okay by the way no but i feel
that 100
um because that's like how i felt when
like you were pregnant you know and like
i'm like what about me so you know what
like let the little people get something
okay okay the patreon is like quaking
for your pregnancy and i'm like over
here having a bender like we couldn't be
on more different levels and that's why
either a jacket there's something for
everyone that's what's so beautiful
about the patreon there's something for
everyone there are so many vlogs there
are so many episodes so head over there
because we have some great stuff coming
up for october 2 and that vlog was
really a treat to watch i felt like and
we really didn't catch up a lot while
you you're on your trip we didn't
facetime like we normally do so i really
felt like i was experiencing your trip i
feel all caught up i feel really good
about it i'm so glad and i just know how
much i love the patreon that like
literally i'm in a bathing suit for half
the vlog yeah no you are giving us
everything that you have i'm giving you
a chest i'm giving you legs i'm giving
you it all mm-hmm you are in my heart
and soul and i get deep
she does get deep about you know some
personal struggles and personal
struggles yeah
so check it out enjoy and there's just
so many perks to being a patreon member
these days like
i said i just couldn't see why not you
know
all season pre-sale season you guys
yesterday was the craziest day it's kind
of the day i've been dreading like
literally since the pandemic started i
like low-key love the pandemic because
you know
my first tour was so big and like so
great and we broke so many barriers and
then you just become like old news you
know like and you like i don't know i
was just like dreading it i'm like do
people still want to come i don't know
so yesterday was a great day and i
wanted to thank everyone for showing up
during the pre-sale there was a couple
sold out shows boston has been added a
second show
pre-sale continues today into tomorrow
morning and then if you're not a patreon
member on my instagram will be all the
links everything will be completely open
to all the shows and i hope that
everyone can come
so yeah yesterday was just like the
busiest day of my [ __ ] life and i had
to leave my house at night which you
know i hate doing on the weekdays busy
busy meetings meetings meetings tickets
tickets tickets podcast podcast podcast
merch drop merch drop merch drop
merge merge merge merch
[Music]
by the way we got so many positive
comments about our gorgeous rendition of
the final story song yesterday yeah so i
think that we'll use that
feedback and we'll take that into
today's episode
in and in every endeavor that we do you
know in every endeavor that we do yeah i
feel really good about that what also i
feel good about is that we have the real
hot stuff of beverly hills part one
reunion recap today and you know what
for part one it was pretty good yeah we
have a lot to talk about and i do feel
like they were giving us like splashes
of erica t just to keep us
satiated until part four and that works
for me did you watch carcelo matcha
weapons live i didn't okay i did with
amber tamlin who like
it was like just the garcelle show you
know it's like but it's good and like
amber's here too it was just like weird
for amber
um
any tea yes okay we'll talk about it
when we recap beverly hills it was a
good episode and she looked
sickening
well i started i it
when i record beverly hills now they
just record watch what happens live and
give themselves the view it's a way to
cheat the right how nice for them and so
i saw the beginning but then i was like
you know what it's getting late and i
should start read i should transition to
reading so i started the new sophie
kinsella book party crasher it's really
cute she can do no wrong sophie can sell
it but it's definitely not my favorite
got it well that what shop inside was
was filled with juicy tidbits you know
her garcelle doesn't hold back great
can't wait to hear all about it so i
think we should just jump right in
without further ado
where are you sitting by yet auntie it
is time for the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
you really didn't have to bring that up
again rub it in my face sorry today's
episode of the morning toast is brought
to you by legacy box are you holding on
to boxes of old home videos to share
with friends and family can you even
watch that priceless footage well your
girls literally had an entire storage
unit full of like old vhs cassettes
things like videos and photos from when
we were kids we had no idea what to do
with it and enter legacy box the
greatest invention of all time the
company i wish i came up with it is your
chance to have aging tapes films and
photos all digitally preserved so the
ability to relive your family history is
never lost because of a leaky pipe or
summer days that make your attic hot
that will melt your tapes
so it's really the easiest service ever
how it works is that you will use their
kit to safely send your vhs's whatever
you have that is old um their team will
create a digital archive by hand in the
usa and then you'll receive your new
copies stored on a cloud a thumb drive a
dvd along with the original media that
you sent them they have a tracking
system that keep you up to date on the
entire process it's really a no-brainer
and it's a great gift for like a sibling
or a mother we did it and it was
literally like the most easy process and
it was the best day ever when you get
that stuff back and you just watch it so
seamlessly like on a thumb drive such a
great thing to do over the holidays if
you plan correctly now yeah and we have
an offer visit legacybox.com toast to
take advantage of this limited time
offer for 40 off so again the exclusive
offer today is at legacybox.com
toast and you can take advantage of it
today and use the kit whenever you're
ready so it's legacy box dot com toast
to save forty percent off legacy box dot
com slash toast thank you claudia it's a
pleasure
doing business with you it is a pleasure
doing business with you it really is
our first story casey musgraves is
responding to the grammys excluding her
new album star cross from the country
category so we briefly mentioned this
yesterday is just like a passing tidbit
that we thought was an interesting
factoid but it turns out it's actually a
lot deeper casey musgraves is making her
feelings known about the recent decision
that has excluded her new album star
cross from the country music category at
the grammys her fifth studio album has
reportedly been deemed ineligible for
the country album category and will
instead compete in the pop category at
next year's awards ceremony
on wednesday casey posted a series of
pictures to her instagram story in
response to the move that was made
public in a letter written to the
recording academy by cindy maebe who's
the president of her record company
universal music group so the president
of casey's record company wrote a letter
to the grammys and
casey posted on her instagram a series
of stories saying you can take the girl
out of the country genre but you can't
take the country out of the girl and
which is a famous line from my favorite
casey musgrave song dime store cowgirl
you can take me out of the country
but you can take the country out of me
no
well she could have just said that no or
like played a clip or something and used
the music feature on instagram and you
could see the lyrics and then she also
did a slideshow of her with like country
icons saying like ain't that right at
loretta lynn official she also tagged
shania twain george strait willie nelson
dolly parton and reba mcintyre and then
at the end she posted a picture of her
you know head to toe in one of her
country looks with middle fingers so
then i was like oh
she wants to become she's not pleased
with she wants to be considered country
she's not pleased that they moved her to
the pop category so in this letter that
the president of the record company she
asked the grammys to quote fully
understand the importance of casey
musgraves to country music the idea that
a handful of people including
competitors who would benefit from casey
not being in the country category are
deciding what is country only
exacerbation
[Music]
so they're saying that
a handful of people like the recording
academy decided this including
competitors i don't know who that would
be would benefit from casey not being in
the country category or deciding what is
country only exacerbates the problem
okay i do have to say i do think
first of all casey busgraves with all
these pictures of her she's country
bonafide country gal i don't think
anyone can take that away from her um
but i've listened to casey mustard since
day one it's something i pride myself on
and
i think golden hour was even a little
bit of a stretch as being country
and star-crossed is not country like
it's not and you can be a country person
and live in nashville and write your
songs in nashville and and want to be
country but at the end of the day
i guess like a genre is a social
construct like what is country but it's
not country yeah you know what this
reminds me of red yes because
red was considered a country album even
though it is completely a pop album just
like taylor hadn't billed it as a pop
album so of course it won all the
country categories and then her next
album which was like now this is pop
it's like you don't
the music is what it is right no and i
this also reminds me when justin bieber
like was upset because he wrote like a
full
r b
album and the grammy said categorized it
as like christian music or something so
or vice versa i don't remember he was
really he was pop when he wanted to be r
b so like i don't know at the end of the
day
a genre is a social construct like how
do you decide like what's pop it's like
a sound but as you know i think someone
who's you know very well read in country
music like star cross is not at all
country yeah and like golden hour which
i even thought was like her poppiest
work yet
like had twinges of country so like
ready
i can't speak sorry
golden hour was her red
yes
but no because that would make this her
1989 which like taylor said it was pop
you know i just mean in the sense of
like the transitional work of art
yeah yeah it's all true like they're all
transitioned from from each other yeah
but no they usually they transition and
stay within genre like for me star cross
and this is what we spoke about last
week
i don't like love it like it's so
different you know golden hour was
different than her previous works but
still like was so casey yeah this is
like
such a departure yeah honestly
i mean
it's kind of like a silly thing to be
like so
uh
it's just
it is what it is i mean it's it's pop
like yeah and i don't
i don't know what the big like then that
should be an achievement for her that
she's crossed categories and the grammys
successful
yeah i think like when it comes to
winning it's probably way easier to win
in the country category than it is to
win in the pop category up against like
taylor swift and
billy eilish lizzo yeah yeah it's harder
to be in that category for sure so i
think like probably like a little life
hack is like release a country album
but
sorry like it's just not country like
that's and it's very simple yeah and i
thought she was doing it on purpose so
to hear that she's upset about it i'm
like oh this whole time i thought like
you were fully changing your purpose
yeah you were transitioning in and out
of genres that's like the biggest
thing in our yeah the biggest flex for
an artist is like i'm not a one-trick
pony
i can win in country i can win and pop i
can and you know what i don't even think
actually that star-crossed is pop i
think it's like alternative it's very
different
so i don't know if there's a category
for alternative but that's like what pop
is now like billy eilish yeah i guess
it's very billy eilish yeah
interesting stuff
interesting stuff man yeah well we still
support but i would love like a true
country casey album next like that's
just kind of what i'm craving i i do
worry that this will push her further
away from country even though the
recording academy is not a part of
country music but i think what that
letter from her president said was that
like people in country
organize this which i don't think they
have the power to like who i don't know
but like literally this morning i
listened to like old-ass casey like
album one like those random songs like
finally got a flashing light they put it
in last year i forgot that song is
called but
like it's so good like i just love that
music and so i'm all for growth i'm all
supportive of it i would love like a
very casey country album
i think you'll be waiting a while i know
i've been saying the same thing with
taylor swift yeah we got betty yeah but
now we get like new kind like as they
transition to different genres we get
new country artists that's true we're
putting out some really great stuff
that's literally how we got casey the
lauren elena album is sickening lauren
elena
must be recognized for being literally
like someone who cannot write a bad song
who refuses to release anything less
than something stellar yeah no it's
really true there's so many good you're
right like up and coming country artists
okay our next story kim kardashian says
her daughter north tells her your house
is so ugly when she's upset with mom
kim shares that her eldest daughter will
sometimes criticize her home decor when
upset over a disagreement on a new
installment of ellen's digital mom mom
confessions web series the keeping up
alum reveals that eight-year-old north
whom she shares with kanye will tell her
that their house is ugly during an
argument she said every time i get into
some kind of disagreement with my
daughter north she thinks this is a dig
to me she'll say your house is so ugly
it's all white who lives like this
first of all north it's your house too
she just thinks it like gets to her and
it's kind of also kind of mean because
kim likes her house no for an
eight-year-old it's a very creative
insults like
who lives like this who lives and then
also like
i don't know when i used to say things
to be like i hate you like yeah normal
no but north is just on another level
from all campers like psychologically
north is supreme that's what i'm hearing
here we we've known i feel and but every
time we get like a little snippet of
north it's just like like north is
it's really like nori's black book you
know literally it's literally that what
is
up with like kim and ellen like why are
the kardashians obsessed with ellen it's
like the one thing i don't understand
i don't know but maybe ellen was someone
who like in you know embrace them from
the beginning and has always like had
them on and take taking them seriously
and i can't see that actually have
happening like ellen taking them
seriously like ellen is like mean to
everyone there's obviously some good
blood there yeah i think chris and ellen
are like really good friends like
i don't know like would kim ever do a a
web series for like a motherhood.com
like so [ __ ] random but like ellen
okay no but i yes but you know what we
really at the end of the day we benefit
from this course of course we got this
cute [ __ ] factoid yeah which is so
hysterical
and
it's just it's so funny but oh i saw
yesterday that kim like won the house in
the divorce yes but like it's very much
kanye
aesthetic aesthetic so i wonder if
she'll be you know putting out any
family photos on the mantel anytime soon
yeah cause like as much as i really
really respect like
the whole vibe you know the arches and
like the not one piece of dust or
clutter you know it is a home with five
children and like i don't know four
four children like
i don't know i just think like there
should be like pillows and stuff it's
like
i actually the more i i
live the more i strive for a home like
kim's where there's nothing in sight but
like where do they keep their things
like they obviously have to have a room
that's like stuff with stuff like
where's your stuff where are your
chargers yes so i'm very much of the
same mindset like declutter
your life
but like you can leave like a picture
frame or like a pillow
i don't know maybe now that kanye's gone
like there will be a throw pillow so she
got the hidden hills home and he put his
idaho place wyoming yeah
on the market which is crazy i wonder
why i wonder why also but then he also
bought that place in malibu
oh yeah the garage for 60 million
dollars yeah
so
interesting really closer to the kids
also i feel like north should know that
she's insulting her father when she says
that right it's not so much kim that's
very true though kim does like it and it
is really nice-looking it is and i feel
like it's actually made her like so
famous like people are obsessed like
with her sinks yeah she's like the most
recognizable bathroom in the world yeah
so like of course she loves that but
like doesn't she ever just want to like
i don't know do a puzzle like where are
the puzzles
when the kids want to like play cards
like where are the cards i don't know
what if she wants to light a candle
where the matches that's a great
question where are the candles
no it's such a good question it's crazy
these are the things
that i think about that i want no i do i
would like to see the room where they
keep their things yeah like it's
probably scary like hoarders yeah like
everyone has like a junk drawer they
have like a junk
[Laughter]
okay like even her closet where she
films all those like skims things it's
literally like a rod with three items so
she has a closet where she actually
keeps her things where she does in film
yeah i would love to see it have they
done a spread
about their home
yes and they did a video it was really
cute gotta rewatch that look for any
hidden doors yeah to where all the
clutter hangs
okay ready for our next story it's a
little crazy sponsorship news speaking
of crazy sponsors today's episode is
brought to you by jenny kane and they're
actually the opposite of crazy they make
the most sickening mules
that come in leather suede shearling and
more it's their classic shoe that's
started at all they're effortless
effortlessly comfortable and they come
in endless versatile options that you
can look put together in an instant so
the wardrobe necessities are honestly
sometimes the hardest to find like you
have crazy things but you never have
like a normal cardigan you know like
neutral things that you can wear a lot
you can layer um and that's really what
jenny kane is all about they believe
that getting dressed should be the
easiest part of your routine they offer
polished basics that will never go out
of style they make everyday moments a
breeze they have curated stylish staples
that work with everything in your closet
in the simplest way to make you look put
together in an instant you might already
have a favorite sweater or pair of shoes
but if it doesn't make you say i'll
never take it off and it isn't jenny
kane actually one of my favorite
cardigans coming for fall winter is
jenny kane it's very very comfortable
very loose it looks great style it
different ways it really is like the
perfect thing you can wear them a
million times such like a nancy meyers
vibe all of their stuff it's like i have
a sweater from them that's oatmeal and i
just i really feel like i'm having lots
of white wine by the sea yeah like
contemplating divorce
find your forever pieces at
jennycaine.com and get 15 off your first
order when you use code toast at
checkout that's j e n n i k a y n e dot
com promo code toast that's a good promo
code you should use it 100
100 okay our next story is some
interesting sponsorship news and i think
you're gonna find it particularly
interesting for one reason which i'm
sure you'll put together shortly okay
the nfl is taking the super bowl
halftime sponsorship rights to market as
their deal with pepsi is set to expire
taylor swift taylor swift pepsi owns the
sponsorship rights for the super bowl
halftime show and a deal that's set to
expire after 2022. one expert estimates
the value of the halftime show to the
nfl is in the range of the 25 million to
50 million that's a year a per year yes
so pepsi obtained the show rights in
2012 as part of a more significant
marketing deal valued at over 2 billion
before that auto parts manufacturer
bridgestone held the show's rights and
paid up to 10 million annually so it's
not clear how much a brand would pay but
using just uh estimates like for a
30-second ad at the super bowl it's 6.5
million dollars
applying that to a 12-minute halftime
show would make it about 150 million
dollars but cnbc says it's unlikely that
that's what a brand will pay okay
so obviously the first thing i think of
here is taylor swift and for those who
don't know here's a little back story is
that taylor swift was a diet coke
ambassador for many many years during
her red era honestly there's some of the
most iconic commercials and photos like
just go watch them they're so cute and
like
i've never related to taylor swift more
than like her drinking diet coke writing
songs like that's literally me except i
don't write songs
so when it comes time every year for the
halftime show a lot of people are always
like where's taylor swift and so for a
while she was contractually not allowed
to do it because she was the face of
diet coke but then even years after that
like there is a non-compete it has been
so long that i actually don't think now
the reason why she's never done the
super bowl halftime show is because of
that i feel like there's other reasons
but like she literally
at the start of the 1989 era like the
night before the super bowl had like the
biggest concert ever like right outside
the stadium like like direct tv yeah or
uh yeah maybe it was att something like
that yeah so there's always that there's
always that i don't know what the reason
is why she's never done it when it seems
like a perfect fit like when we're
always thinking of people like pink
people who have endless categories of
music that people from all different
walks of life enjoy taylor swift is
really that [ __ ] like blank space
there's so many songs like
so i don't really even know if they do
change sponsors to like
the morning toast
if she would do the morning shows
halftime show which sounds so good by
the way we should really go start a
gofundme and it would be the best
halftime show it would be like we have
taste like it would be like kelly
clarkson opens the show pink shows up
maybe beyonce shows up and then like
taylor swift closes it out like it would
be we would literally you know we would
do we would recreate that pepsi
commercial with pink beyonce and who was
the third one
christine aguilera yes
was it
i think i feel like oh britney spears
sorry oh yeah yeah um that's what i
would do and i would have everyone in
the stadium be a part of it because you
know how in the in the commercial
they're all like yeah
i would make everyone do that oh by the
way they should free idea free idea no i
buys it again that's what they should do
i look forward to seeing who comes in
what they do with the space i wonder if
they have influence over the
performers i imagine they do or they at
least have to approve it yeah i imagine
that they do so i think
you know this could be a big opportunity
for someone but it's also possible that
pepsi will just buy it again
if they were happy with their investment
i mean honestly for me
i actually love diet pepsi but i
understand you know the landscape that
is the soda industry like pepsi is so
like lame compared to coke like sorry um
but i actually think pepsi having this
halftime show was like they're the
coolest thing about the brand like they
should really keep it
yeah they're always losing to cody i
don't know but you're saying they're
still look they've been they've had this
spot for now 10 years after this year
and like they're still losers it didn't
work okay hear me sorry i would like to
offer a different perspective i'm glad
you brought that up
i think they were way looser-y before
the halftime show and now they're like
they're they compete the thing is you'll
never be better than cook so you just
gotta be different and the halftime show
i really believe set them apart it was
like such a big deal yeah i could i
would i would be down to see someone
else come yeah like who has that much
money
i know maybe like a tech company oh
please no the uber halftime show
enough honestly you know what it's going
to be like the facebook halftime show
that's that's like the only company that
has any money because they're like i
don't know like stealing all our data
and [ __ ] yeah and selling it yeah it's
literally going to be the first facebook
halftime show mark my words because you
know that that sounds [ __ ] miserable
i actually wouldn't watch like even if
taylor swift like i in my soul i
couldn't do it no me neither
okay we'll keep you posted this is some
interesting news shaking it up what if
it was like the netflix halftime show
even though that wouldn't make any sense
because it's like a streaming service
yes cable they wouldn't do it yeah no i
think it's going to be like uh
i think it'll be a tangible brand
probably not tech brand because like the
tech companies they don't need this
platform and like the super bowl is so
honestly you know would be a good one
like doritos well that would be like
frito yeah it is owned by pepsi yeah
pepsi literally frito light is pepsi so
it would be the same yeah but like who
kills it at the super bowl with their
commercials doritos is always really
good yeah but so may but they should
stick to that yeah oh my god my fingers
are unbelievably swollen
are you okay am i going through like
look i almost didn't get my rings off
should i put them back on now yeah let
them breathe what about these oh my god
what is going on is it a lot of salt
i did have like a whole pizza for dinner
last night but that's not salty it's not
salty
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah i'm just like concerned but it'll
be okay
some exciting hallmark news that i think
you're reviewing jen funny hn you know
tis the season desperate housewives
alums
terry hatcher and james denton aka mike
delfino and susan meyer are reuniting in
hallmark channel movie a kiss before
christmas oh that's cute that's so cute
it will be a desperate housewives
reunion on the hallmark channel two
former stars of the abc drama will
headline the kiss before christmas a
holiday movie that will premiere during
the cable channel's annual countdown to
christmas programming event it's the
first time the pair has worked together
since desperate housewives ended in
2012. as you know their characters had
an on-again off-again relationship
during the series so mike delfino aka
the man has actually been in quite a few
i've seen him in like a lot of these
like he's so hallmarky hallmarky movies
i
do not hold a place in my heart for
terry hatcher like but that's just
because of susan no it's also because of
terry the beef she like started all the
beef on the set and i think part of the
reason why they like ended it
maybe sooner than it would have was
because of her like no one could get
along with her yeah it was like a toxic
workplace due large in part to terry
allegedly allegedly you sound like erica
jane i know but it's such a great word
it just gets you off the [ __ ] no
allegedly it does
the movie uh a real estate development
executive mike delfino is married
obviously why would the woman in a
hallmark movie be the real estate
executive
um
yeah i'm trying to like see what her
backstory is but she's just the key to
him being able to reclaim his oh right
yeah
that's so [ __ ] twisted
anyways he's a real estate development
executive and he's married father with
two teens on christmas eve he's
disappointed to learn he's losing out on
promotion and laments that his nice guy
way of doing business has held him back
his
career so he's a failed real estate
mogul thanks to some christmas magic
ethan's casual wish that his life had
taken a different course becomes reality
he wakes up the next morning and is
shocked to find everything is different
he isn't married to joyce terry hatcher
he doesn't have two teenage kids and
he's ceo of his company so it's you know
a real
a real choice what would you rather the
love or the success
joyce is the key to ethan being able to
reclaim his original life in the family
he loves they're always asking the tough
questions at hallmark they are
they are and it's it's good to see he'll
probably make the choice of family i
mean i assume it's on the homework
channel um i have to say like you know
364 days a year like i'm a card carrying
feminist like equality for all i don't
know when those hallmark movies start to
play i'm like you in the kitchen
man back to work like i don't know
there's something about like the
traditional i'm like yeah make that pie
[ __ ] make it
get the tree while your husband works
like no husband gets the tree you pick
it out no you know what i mean like i
become so
like
traditional yeah you're just a
traditional girly but don't at me
because the other days of the year like
women in the boardroom
but
hallmark women in the bedroom
[Laughter]
that's hysterical anyway so that's
really exciting i love when people who
have acted together like act together
again i always hope that it'll be you
know in some way like a sequel like
maybe
james was a plumber ethan sorry yeah
well i don't want to spoil anything but
it's not possible
what do you mean that this would be a
sequel
oh someone goes do you know what i'm
saying i don't want to spoil because if
you haven't watched desperate housewives
you're cheating yourself out of one of
the life's greatest luxuries like one of
your greatest pleasures so i'm not gonna
spoil anything
even though i feel like i already did i
don't even know what you're talking
about okay so i'll tell you later um but
treat yourself it's on netflix or hulu
what's on there yeah it's amazing
amazing stuff i think it's on hulu okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
allow me just to move my microphone back
slightly
it's really like someone said this in
one of the comments um
it's from confessions of a teenage drama
queen when the nutty drama teacher is
like
pressure bars yeah that's how we feel
before we sing
one two three it's the final story
[Music]
women in the bedroom
theo's like you woke me for that
good morning theo it's your mother
he's like going through this like
teenage like empty faces yeah
at least in his rebellion he's going to
his auntie he's not going to you know
turn back turning to drugs turning to
drugs hanging out with bad kids bad
influences
no like magnolia yeah she's trouble
magnolia grew up on the wrong side of
the tracks magnolia
just she just has that that spirit in
here that you can't break can i tell you
something so i went to an event last
night for simon and magnolia was there i
wish
um
no so i went to an event for my friend
simon and phil they started a candle
company and by the way i took home two
gift bags you will love the candles
actually ben ben took home too and you
opened it by the way he literally walked
into the bedroom and said i love this
candle lit it and left
like the first rule of candle etiquette
you can't just leave a candle like you
have to watch it like well you were in
there no like you just left it whatever
that sound i was saying so you know it's
like this you know event like there were
influencers there and they're like all
these like influencers and they were
like oh my god we're obsessed with
margaret like we saw her last weekend
like i literally became margo's sister
like like i think i'm so great i
launched my tour walk into a party like
you're margo sister i'm like yeah who
are you and they're like we're best
friends with margaret we [ __ ] love
margot i'm like yes she's the coolest
but like i'm claudia they're like yeah
we know like mark is the best i'm like
yeah she's fine
margot's sister what a beautiful thing
to be known as yeah and then i told
margo and she was like
why wasn't i invited to the event and
i'm like that's a good question i don't
know i'm sorry well everyone was talking
about her yeah it's better to be missed
you know
okay our fifth and final story is like a
little interesting tech health news
apple is studying the potential of air
pods as a health device so this is
pretty interesting it's like take your
pulse seems to make sense to do a lot of
things
apple inc is studying ways to make air
pods into a health device including for
enhancing hearing like a hearing aid
reading body temperature you know how
you do a thermometer in your ear and
monitoring your posture according to
documents reviewed by the wall street
journal and people familiar with the
plans the plans further demonstrate
apple's ambition to add health and
wellness features to devices beyond the
apple watch where most of the company's
health functions exist today apple is
also working on technology that aims to
use iphones to help diagnose depression
and cognitive decline well with the
iphones are causing depression and
cognitive decline it seems a little
twisted but the earpod thing is actually
really smart first of all it should
totally be a hearing aid like yeah
to amplify the sounds around you if need
be right and then it's like
you know if you're a person who needs a
hearing aid everyone's just wearing air
pods you're just like everyone else like
it's normalizing
hearing devices yeah and the temperature
is a no-brainer a no-brainer love this
yeah isn't that pretty cool i mean
already i'm pretty sure that if you wear
air pods
while you're working out because when i
used to run on the treadmill all the
time like if i wore my air pods it would
count towards my steps in my health app
oh so they're like feeling it already i
think so and if they're not they should
be and so other things like that you
know pulse whatnot i think it would be
great to use those as a health device
totally didn't know how to take your
pulse
um
yeah well
when i was at my retreat we would have
to take our pulse while we were working
out to make sure we were hitting our
goals like i'm literally a vampire i
swear god i don't have a pulse like i've
never felt it in my life oh but but i
was like thinking i was like i'm gonna
feel it i was like why did i never do it
because on all the workout machines you
can just put your hands on the middle
and they'll give you your pulse and
they'll give you your heart rate
is that your pulse
unclear
unclear um
no actually but this is just a really
pertinent story to me because i was on
the apple website literally yesterday i
have airpods in my cart
because i need new airpods because when
we podcast they die we can't do more
than 55 minutes because they die no they
released like the version two of the
airpods so all of a sudden everybody's
version ones went
yeah so i was about to buy new airpods i
still think that i should because this
seems like it'll take a while it's just
an ideation phase but i just want to let
you guys know that they're working on
technology that might actually be
beneficial to our lives and and that's
exciting news you don't really hear very
often no that's fabulous news i'd love
that
um okay well let's dive into the tv
recap because part one of the real
housewives of beverly hills four-part
reunion started last night and it was
very good and you know what seeing the
ladies up close and personal
really kind of highlighted for me how
close they were sitting together and
if that was me like i could never yeah
before we dive in today's episode and
the tv recap is brought to you by noom
instead of setting a strict set of rules
nume is empowering you with the
knowledge to build smarter more
sustainable habits and behaviors they
use a cognitive behavioral approach
where you'll focus on the why instead of
the what to change your relationship
with eating everyone's journey is
different so noon is customizing a
program for you based on your personal
goals where they don't consider food off
limits they help you keep eating foods
that you love while learning to maintain
a healthier balance and if you have an
off day it's totally okay it will not
set you off course noon is just going to
gently help you back on track they asked
for 10 minutes of your day to teach you
about your eating habits and to check in
on your progress more than 80 percent of
newm users have completed the program
and more than 60 percent of users lose 5
or more of their body weight they've
published over 25 peer-reviewed
scientific journal articles about the
science that goes into their approach
and it's just going to help you achieve
a healthier lifestyle for whatever
reason that may be
whether you want to finish your clothes
better you want to feel better
that's totally up to you start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial at
noom.com toast that's n o o m dot com
slash toast i know you've had a lot of
success with new mj queen i love noom
whether whatever phase of you know your
lifestyle you are at whether you're in
the weight loss phase or maintenance
phase you just want to keep an eye on
what you are doing and track your habits
noom is such a great asset i recommend
it to everyone who's starting out it's
really hard to know where to start when
you are embarking on a fitness journey
and noom has all of the tools like
educational tools and also the um
tools to help you track everything that
you're doing it's a wonderful resource
and platform all right let's dive in so
we got part one everyone was there kathy
joined us for the part one so do you
think she's there for all four now no
still no no i think she'll be on for
next and i shall probably leave
eventually i actually cackled when andy
asked her if she knew where she was i
know i was like
i didn't think it looked that similar
not at all does she have a million
statues like that no and they they show
the side by side so it's a brick
i didn't understand it at all yeah
so part one we didn't really tackle
obviously like the big major stuff they
did give us like bits and pieces of the
erica stuff but it was really like
garcelle versus the world yeah and i
feel very torn on the garcelle thing let
me say why because like i thought i i
don't ever want to side with lisa reyna
i think lisa rena was just siding with
jory because she just like [ __ ] hates
carcel but when it comes to the erica
stuff i think garcelle is like so on the
money like i really like side with her
completely but when it comes to her
being a housewife i do think darit was
making some like decent points like she
is very jab jab jab especially in her
confessionals and yes everyone is but
garcelle does it the most and i think
the worst and then like really says
nothing to the women face to face and
that must be frustrating to like really
feel like you're hanging out with
someone you know like zero about what
they're thinking yeah so i didn't feel
like it was fair for rena and dorit to
keep ganging up on
garcelle especially when like first of
all it's between garcelle
and dory like i need renaissance to shut
up like
but jerry like was making some decent
points about like garcelle as a friend i
i hear that i do i think that and also
garcelle is a housewife like i think
dorit had said that she was checked out
and garcelle was like i always show up
and i think but it's like a chicken and
egg situation because i feel like darite
feels like garcelle isn't involved in
the group but garcelle feels like she's
not in the inner circle so which is true
so if right which is true because there
is this fab five right without teddy
there it's for and they are real friends
and so when they're doing the show
they're very invested in it because
these are their friends these are their
lives for garcelle it's it's more so
like a these are my co-workers and i'm
not going to give them every piece of
myself that's very true and because like
those relationships like they need to be
earned so i feel like what do reid's
feeling is it's true
but what garcel's feeling is true you
don't just like get my love and
friendship when you guys kind of keep me
at an arm's length that's so [ __ ]
true like that fab five is so toxic and
the thing is these things just take time
but like no one's giving it any time and
yes it must be frustrating and the thing
the reason why i don't have an issue
with the fact that garcelle you know is
shady and her confessionals is because
she's saying what everyone's thinking
yeah so you know because it's facts i'm
like well where's the lie and you know
what really bothered me in the
conversation with rena and garcelle
amongst a million things was like rinna
was just so annoyed that like denise
kept getting brought up and then she
kept asking garcelle like what is it
about me that you don't like like what
is it that we can't get past and she
doesn't want garcelle to keep bringing
up the denise thing but of course it's
the denise singh look what you did to
your friend of 20 years on a public why
the [ __ ] would i be friends with you
we've been friends for just as long and
obviously means nothing to you right so
like the fact that
rina like kind of cornered garcelle and
to not be bringing it up like get over
it already it was a year ago soon
garcelle didn't say anything but at the
end of the day of course it's about
denise yeah no and i think you know it's
not like she's upset on benitez's behalf
waiting for an apology but it is like
this is how you treat your lifelong
friends and fa and you discard them you
know at embarrass them embarrass them in
order to you know be closer with these
women or for the show or just to like
for the political world of real
housewives and who wants to be
collateral damage in that i i mean the
issue between the two of them is that
they really don't [ __ ] like each
other as people and so when brenda came
over to garcia was like i love you and
it's like but you know you don't
but you don't like you don't even like
her and then we were talking last night
on facetime so i just wanted to remember
to say this again because i said this to
you which was that so garcelle say at
the beginning of the season garcelle and
marina had a daytaunt and it's like i'm
open to moving forward let's see if we
can get there which i think is a very
fair place to start and then throughout
the season garcelle felt like brenna
didn't have her back and then rina says
it's because i didn't agree with you so
rina never agrees with what garcelle is
thinking or feeling when you are friends
with someone yes of course sometimes you
don't agree with them you call them out
sure but generally speaking you agree
with their basic premise and their line
of thinking right so the fact that in
every argument that garcelle was in the
season and there were many rina never
thought garcelle was right you clearly
don't agree with you're fundamentally
like not aligned as friends yeah
you know what else i really liked about
last night's episode
was kind of just pointing out how
there's so many double standards in the
group like literally nobody comes after
eric i'm like
if anyone else spoke to sutton the way
that erica was like threatening her like
or what
everyone would be shocked and it's like
erica just gets this pass and it's like
so unfair yeah
poor son
yeah well i'm sure we will get to all of
that also son's boyfriend broke up with
her that was really sad
but she has a really great outlook about
it she looks great too yeah no she's
sutton's a cutie like she's quirky she's
misunderstood for sure misunderstood
she's emotional but she really owns it
all and i think that she's a really good
friend to everyone and i feel like and i
said this when crystal was fighting with
her in the beginning of the season like
she just takes a minute to figure out
but i feel like they got there i feel
like they got there they have mutual
friends who tell them that they're so
similar like they would actually love
each other like they're fine and they
knew that they would be fine it's not
that deep like sutton really doesn't
have conflict she's a very like caring
person she's just quirky she's just
weird yes so like you get a weird read
on her yeah um what else happened kathy
showed up and was just like giving me
life i just love her
um andy did press erica on a bunch of
stuff she's coming out like
i'm innocent
these women have doubted me and it's
unacceptable and i'm here to clear my
name and on watch weapons live they did
a poll like part one like do you feel
like you're gonna feel differently about
erica's situation
at the end it was like 80 20 now
yeah i mean erica she's made some decent
points which is that like there's no
need for her to be fired just yet i
think that we said that like let the the
um
just assist justice system like do its
thing you are innocent until proven
guilty and if if
i i think that that's pretty fair it's
just
very damning yeah of course you know and
andy said like even by the time we
record this till when it airs like more
stuff is going to come out and literally
you saw yesterday bravo's been
subpoenaed to hand over on air footage i
keep seeing that headline is like new i
feel like we we report like yeah it does
feel like it's been repetitive yeah um
the other thing i wanted to say was this
conversation between rena and garcelle
like rina getting up and like hugging
her and like literally forcing her
giving her no choice but to say like
okay is so fraudulent like rina's just
i'm sorry she's 100 miley's favorite
person on the cast and i was like so
into her for so long she's so
performative like in everything she does
do you think she said that thing about
race
i don't know
and perhaps she said a version of it so
it's not exactly what garcelle said she
said so that way she could sit there and
say i never said that but what garcelle
was feeling but someone related to
garcelle isn't untrue either yeah for
sure so i'm sure it's somewhere the
truth is somewhere in the middle and on
watch happens live like
garcelle basically said like yeah we
left the reunion fine but like i know
who lena is like and and like it's
almost like they've made no progress
like yeah no it it
it is what it is like i don't expect
them to ever move forward because they
do have so much history and you see the
way that rena blindly supports her
friends erica like
she doesn't give that to barcelona
that's her friend a good point her
friend of 20 years like garcelle knows
garcelle has eyes like she can see that
right look what you do for she's not
treating me like a friend yet you want
to sit there and come over to my couch
and tell me that you love me like but
you don't oh my god that's the best
point you've ever [ __ ] made thank you
like how she blindly supports erica but
then she's like well i didn't agree with
you in your fight with jared about
nothing about like [ __ ] about
nonsense so you won't back her up but
you'll back your friend up who's like
probably guilty of fraud
yeah
damn
okay and then when kathy came i'm like
why is kathy like larry sitting on
garcelle and kyle's lap like just for
kathy who's like this regal woman oh on
watch happens live they said there was a
question who do you think is richer
kathy or crystal sutton
and they were like cathy like cathy's so
rich yeah so um for her just to be
sitting like wedged between like all
these housewives i'm like
that's not right it's not right
oh we got a package we got a package
what do we think it is it's chocolates
oh wow thank you so much can you just
pop it on the table thank you so much
linda no you're good
i know people didn't like when we opened
the package but that's a package of oh
yeah from the lint chocolatiers that was
something in the reviews that they
didn't like that we opened a package on
the show and that we ordered lunch and
you know if i'm gonna
concede anything maybe it was annoying
to order lunch on the show but we only
did it so that we would have the stamina
to record a patreon after anyways
claudia is about to open this package
from lin just be careful with the
address ma'am yes ma'am
okay
i'm here and i'm sorry like i couldn't
just let this box
lint chocolatiers wow this is
exciting i thought maybe at first it was
just someone using a lint box but i
checked the return address
and it's from the linda
it's from belgium
it's from belgium it was swiss
whatever
okay
this whole big box oh god we have three
sets
oh my god that's so annoying i thought
we're gonna get like
oh okay
first up again this is not an ad this is
the lindor milk chocolate truffle bar
should we try yeah mukbang no they hate
when we eat on the podcast put it down
put it down claude we'll do this later
okay but also the show we were about to
be done so double chocolate milk
chocolate truffles we're about to be
done are you telling me to stop i'm
telling you to stop i think yeah
i'm just saying not to be a [ __ ] that
inside of that box like smells like duty
so like i don't know how the chocolate's
gonna taste but like it smells like the
the box has been sitting in the
cardboard like wet i feel like i'm going
to smoke a cigar
these smell fine this is why he's
definitely eating this this is what
people do before they have cigar
literally
theo don't eat it okay well that was
gonna be a wrap on beverly hills anyway
anything else you watch i'm still
watching made it's very it's very very
good but it's very pit-inducing and i'm
realizing i'm only gonna be watching it
while the sun is out oh the shows like
that can trauma like give you drama but
it's not even that traumatic or or
graphic or anything it's just like a lot
to sit with so
um also thank you to linde for finally
getting theo back over to claudia's
couch yes i love you my angel everyone
thank you so much for listening
tomorrow's friday so celebrate okay
anything else
no just keep your eyes peeled for toast
merch updates launching on tuesday
claudius tickets are available for
pre-sale now and they go on sale to the
general public tomorrow but you know
getting them via pre-sale is a great
reason to join patreon patreon.com
morning toast where we just dropped a
new vlog we have over 250 episodes there
that could really get you into 2022 and
it's really premium content so many
vlogs so many good times so many
memories so many laughs so much premium
content and we hope that you will
consider joining us thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast
milania morning show where we deal with
the fact that stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as popular podcast we found so
specified institutional publication
against maxwell please favorite
somebody's father's mortgage on those
vibes whatever you're doing
if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you're true
toaster you're a part of the society
season two and to let us know that you
actually listened to the end of the
episode why don't you go to our most
recent instagram and put a picture of
the chocolate bar in honor of today's
thinking same thing have a great day you
guys will see you tomorrow for
friday friday
bye